[موسيقى]
تويتر في الواقع يعني
ظهر علانيه كبيره ومستر ماسك يغير
الجروب حق تويتر وخلاها عدد قليل من الناس
وقد
يفشل لا سمح الله ولكن هي في النهايه رؤيا
وهي رساله اعلاميه قويه عندك محتوى ما
عندك محتوى
اجلب المحتوى انا محتوى عند واحد نظيف
افضل من 100 محتوى غير مجدي لا لها تاثير
سلبي زي ما صار في اسهم سمعنا طاحت زي ما
صار انه اي شخص يقدر ياخذ اسمك ويثق
بالحساب باسمك وهو مو انت يعني
مع الفتواتر كتير فحس الان اكتر زياده هذا
شيء ينفرني من التطبيق اني ما هاعمل حساب
فيها ابدا يعني بعد اللي صار ممكن موضوع
انه ممكن اي احد ينتحل شخصيه اي شخص يعني
هذا موضوع مربي كلنا
اكثر من اي احد ثاني فبالتالي اي تغيير
بيطلع الجميع من بدايهنا لحد اعلى يعني
القمه وحقيقه انا اجد انه التقنيه
مهم جدا الواحد اذا بيجي همم يقدر يدخل
ويكتب حساب باسمي ينزل فيه بدون اي
اشتراكات بدون اي عقوبات بدون اي ده صراحه
شيء
مره ما هو سليم يعني
[موسيقى]